tomas de Mesilla was a model Mackle
government minister until recently the
defense minister is a close confidant of
the Chancellor now his ministry has
cancelled a purchase of drones under
accusations of wasting taxpayers money
exit site it's high time everyone owns
up to their responsibilities absolute
Psalms I did he step down he may have
made a mess of things but it wasn't all
just his fault my canon we can only be
forced to step down if he's responsible
for it there are quite a few people
blaming him for things that in the end
he couldn't have been informed about
let's English poet uncle dick should
defense minister tomas de Mesilla step
down fifty-five percent say no around
forty percent of Germans say yes he
should if beneath the mining I don't
think he'll mr. Monsieur should step
down because the responsibility for
these decisions goes back many years it
just ended up on his desk Debbie's yeah
still has the chancellor's full support
Angela Merkel would rather go into the
election campaign with her defence
minister at her side
you